(slow tempo music)
- [Voiceover] No one that
knows me would ever guess
I get paid to do amateur porn.
They all think I'm so proper and ladylike.
- [Voiceover] I'm glad I
don't work in porn anymore.
I'm so disgusted with myself
and I don't ever want to be
reminded of what I have done.
- [Voiceover] I've been in 10
amateur lesbian porn videos
to pay for college.
I don't regret it at all.
- [Voiceover] I worked
in the porn industry
and now all I want to do
is watch people have sex.
- [Voiceover] I have no
idea what to tell my family
when they ask me what my career is.
I'm a porn star and there's
no way I can open up about it.
- [Voiceover] I work in porn and I love it
because I can live out my sexual fantasies
in a safe, controlled space.
- [Voiceover] I am a porn star.
I hate my life and that sex
isn't special to me anymore.
The industry ruined me and my life.
- [Voiceover] Being a
porn star is interesting.
I have hundreds of guys
professing their love everyday.
I'm pretty sure if they really knew me,
they wouldn't say it.
- [Voiceover] I am one
of the least important
people in the industry,
like fetching coffee and stuff.
But I still get to say I work in porn
and guys just eat it up without question.
- [Voiceover] I'm a porn star,
but don't know how to
tell my new girlfriend.
I'm afraid I might scare her away.
- [Voiceover] I distanced myself
from all my family and friends
because I'm too embarrassed to tell them
that I'm a porn star.
- [Voiceover] I'm a porn star
and can't help but wonder
how many people I pass on the street
have seen me naked.
- [Voiceover] Working in porn gave me
a greater sense of self and
higher standards of men.